how many years did you put in before you
really felt comfortable on a stage doing
stand-ups honestly yeah about
or how old were you the first time you
got on a stage I'll try around 19. and
what gave you the courage to step on
that stage what gave me the current I
just I had nothing else I could do
Howard I have no other talents I have no
but you had to be in Show Business it
was your thing I wanted to be a writer
to tell you the truth and I didn't know
how to get into writing right so I you
know it's like okay maybe I'll do this
stand-up thing and maybe somebody will
see that I can write a joke and so when
you go up and you're 19 years old you
still needed a job you had a regular job
I worked at a Red Lobster on Queens
Boulevard
no no I had bad teeth and I was you know
you know it was in the 70s they didn't
have black waiters then right we're
always boys uh these teeth you have now
or not your nationalities these teeth
cost me about 17 grand wow these are
those are nice I did a great job oh yeah
yeah yeah they don't look fake I
specifically I went to Whitney Whitney
Houston's Doctor Who has your old teeth
where are they now
and so Bobby Brown has them lucky you
that's right
and so when you're at Red Lobster and
you tell everyone you're going to go up
on stage somewhere do they look at you
like to be like a [__] idiot and did
your mother think you were a complete
idiot no see when you grow up in a bad
neighborhood people are just happy you
want to do anything right it's like oh
he wants to do something besides smoke
or sell crack you've spoken about
crafting your act you say when you start
writing jokes for your comedy you're
gonna bomb in a sense if you're going to
do new material yeah is that the
scariest thing to be Chris Rock now one
of the greatest stand-ups in the going
shitty materials so to speak it's weird
because on one hand you're bombing but
on the other hand I'm in a little Club
so I have a muscle I could control 300
people yeah but when it starts to go
downhill do you then rely on your rolled
material just to bring them back no no
never never so what is this muscle you
talk about I don't know you have a
muscle you you I have a lovely yes you
do you would you could do a club with
your eyes closed captioning not
available
yeah I want some dough so when you don't
work for three years doing stand-up
aren't you afraid if you stay away for
three years you might never ever want to
get back on the stage I look at it like
the stones like okay the stones don't
work all the time right they put it down
they shut it down and when they do it
it's [__] special and you know you
got to be there right but [__] you
know out of Destiny groups and [__] you
know I can see ZZ Top any week you want
to make it special so when you know when
the Stone's gone when you two's on the
road it's on you know you got to see it
thank you